[Musique]
nous rencontrons ici les fleurs avec le
feuilles de la tige
de sorte que cette zone gmp
faire l'objet d'un traitement ultérieur et ensuite
Peut être coupé et séché
peut devenir
[Musique]
celui que j'aime particulièrement
un travail spécial ici est aussi
unique en Allemagne et
oui et bien sur
alors
Les affaires futures sont tournées vers l'avenir
l'industrie et donc très intéressant
[Musique]
exactement nous produisons actuellement une tonne
par an nous avons généralement tous les deux
Semaines une récolte dans laquelle nous avons ensuite un
tel espace que nous sommes cette année
puis de la récolte voici environ 600
Vous pouvez faire sécher les plantes ici
environ 70 à 80 kilogrammes d'une pièce
récolté et qui se passe dans le continuum
pour ainsi dire, où l'on peut dire avec
Fiers que nous soyons de la maison
Production en Allemagne actuellement 55%
du marché bien que nous ne fournissions que
trois
[Musique]
être et une éducation correspondante
doivent également avoir lieu quels sont les effets
de cannabis sur le corps
néanmoins il faut aussi
Je noterai également ce que
Les effets de l'alcool, par exemple
dans lequel nous sommes depuis 100 ans maintenant
notre société observe et de
Le cannabis d'autre part aussi que
doivent alors être pesés les uns par rapport aux autres
[Musique]